Robert Durst was indicted for illegal
possession of a gun that's the latest
news on oh yeah he's that creepy guy
from that HBO documentary the J yeah
that's right he's this weird old
millionaire but a lot of news about him
and he's been connected with three
different murders maybe even more the
guy gives everyone the willies Oh every
time I think about him I get the willies
I mean I think he's really creepy yeah
well at least he's in custody for the
gun charge they have him locked up for
the gun charge we don't have to worry
about that guy anymore okay well I mean
you say that but he's really sneaky I
mean he's rich he's got connections I
wouldn't be surprised if he's already
managed to get out of jail and gone out
on the lam come on Andy you really think
so oh sure with this kind of money could
be anywhere by now come on Andy anywhere
think that's really possible oh my god
they're with teen I saw him he was right
there oh that was awful I never want to
see that wrinkly lizard face weirdo
again
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well we don't have to worry about that
guy anymore that's done for now we got a
great show from The Twilight Saga and
the new movie clouds sales Maria Kristen
Stewart is on the show
[Applause]
that doesn't even make any sense I can't
even pretend that's scary from the new
Showtime special knock-knock it's taking
the tyro comedians take the town John
Doerr here
plays a German music gasps Brian Wilson
ha hey even little Durst as a fan well
bad Motor Show coming up with like a
break Jimmy let's go
you